all right chris what's that chris uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally i'm originally from baltimore
maryland
and uh tell me about your family growing
up you had both your parents yeah i
had an interesting upbringing i didn't
have a bad childhood um
it was i guess you would say it was
confusing
you know uh my father divorced my mother
and married the next door neighbor when
i was about five
they still live next door to each other
it's literally been 39 years
they're directly next door to each other
um my mother you know back then she
worked for uh
she actually worked for the uh the fbi
uh she told me one time it was her job
to to print the uh
the 10 most wanted list you know back
then there was no internet so i guess it
had to be mailed out but
my father was a totally opposite end of
the spectrum he was more more criminal
element and uh
i leaned more towards
that side of things uh he um he did and
sold drugs and uh
i eventually started stealing drugs from
him and i got
i guess you could say i met my first
girlfriend cocaine when i was about 12
years old
and
he found his coke in my wallet and
he never touched it again
but it was a little late for that the
seed was planted i um
i uh
you know i yeah
when i grew up it was i guess
you would say it's like five six miles
maybe from the uh from the city line you
know it's a
it appears to be a little a nice little
rural you know suburban kind of
community but
like i said it's right down the street
they're selling drugs on the corners and
i
it didn't take long for me to get mixed
up with that kind of [ __ ] down there
um
as i started to get a little older my
early teens maybe uh
the rave scene was starting to become
popular
and i got mixed up in that um pretty
heavily sold a lot of drugs at those
clubs
to the point where i was making more
money than my parents so i dropped out
of high school um
i got introduced to a lot of you know
you hear about the street drugs like
heroin cocaine that kind of thing but i
got introduced to
a lot crazier [ __ ] getting involved with
that
um
you know like
just math and pcp
ecstasy ecstasy ketamine all that kind
of stuff and as a matter of fact my
motto was if it ain't synthetic it's
[ __ ] pathetic
it just
it wasn't a day went by we didn't mix
you know nine different substances
together and [ __ ] just
crazy off the wall [ __ ] but um at around
17 i got my my first place of my own
and i realized at that age
it's an excellent way to make money
or at the very least keep the drug habit
going is to have a house for all that
crazy [ __ ] to go on
you know these days they call them trap
houses but this was 95 that term hadn't
even come out yet um
but uh
yeah man i continued that same behavior
up to the age of 40 when i came out here
to get my [ __ ] together how far did you
go in school huh how far did you want to
school
i dropped down halfway through the 12th
grade you know i ended up going back to
some sort of external diploma program
type of thing you know kind of put them
on smile on my mother's face but i never
used it for anything
but um
yeah man i
me and school never got along that was
the place where you buy and sell drugs
you know what i mean
it had no other purpose
um
but uh you know getting involved with
that racing really kicked addiction in
the ass man like it kicked it in strong
uh
you know i ended up in prison for uh
burglary
um
but uh
before i went to prison i i went to uh
i went through a program called teen
challenge it's a christian discipleship
rehab
uh
i did everything opposite of what i was
supposed to i robbed the [ __ ]
collection plate um
straight up i actually
met a girl at the church and we
conceived a daughter at the church
her name is tiffany it means appearance
or manifestation of god
uh we thought it made sense you know
she's 19 now um
let's see [ __ ] man um
so change team challenge didn't work for
you i it wasn't challenging enough i
guess
now i i definitely um
you know it planted a seed as a result i
have a somewhat of a belief system i
can't say i lean in that direction you
know but um
to this day my nickname is church
just because of my whole involvement
with that thing you know i helped out
with the youth group a good bit and
i don't know it definitely didn't uh
it didn't work you know right back out
to the same old behaviors which like i
said landed me in prison um
when i got out i i've always been an
artist i've been drawing my entire life
you know it was something that
it was it's actually the only constant
you know
even if i were high i can i would sit
down and draw you know
um when i was in prison everybody's
tattooing and i was always drawing and
they were trying to get me involved and
you know i would like burn ink and that
sort of thing but i didn't actually
tattoo in prison because i wanted to
learn it properly properly rather um
when i got out
i sought out an apprenticeship
uh
you know it was
it's difficult industry to break into
back then
um but i managed to pull it off uh you
know before i started tattooing i was
drawing portraits of the ballpoint pen
so i just had to find somebody and i was
impressed enough with
what i was doing
to kind of you know
give me a start give me a spot to start
whatever
um
it didn't take long it blew up um a lot
of suit my own horn but i'm pretty good
at it you know um
doing tattoo conventions and
uh uh just reaching i reached this this
plateau
where
[Music]
it wasn't enough
you know that first four years of my
career i was clean
but only because i used
tattooing as a drug if that makes sense
like i wanted to learn as much as
possible i wanted to grow i wanted to
meet people i wanted to
to become part of like that that whole
community and like i said it wasn't
enough
um
i had a dentist give me percocets
for a root canal
and that took me on a 10-year run
that one prescription
seemed to last a solid decade i uh
when i fell off the wagon i had you know
a quarter million dollar home and a half
acre swimming pool all the toys
i had a girl
uh we had two children you know we were
living together
and um
i always say i we replaced the christmas
tree with a stripper pole when she left
and just kept it moving she left she
took kids with her
and uh
i got back on that whole trap house
routine and it was this house was crazy
at one point we had to pull the carpet
up because there was so much blood all
over
fighting shooting up just
anything you can do with a house to make
money i did
you know
guns drugs prostitution even housed
illegal immigrants at one point
they gave me like 1600 bucks a month to
keep them in the attic um
this is where baltimore
yeah uh as a result of my behavior in
that specific house in that neighborhood
i got arrested six times in five months
uh
two of those arrests were house raids at
the same house
and uh
wow
um i had a i had retained a pretty good
lawyer you know uh
he was actually a lawyer that used to
play cards with my father when i was
growing up oddly enough
but uh he
he was uh able to
i don't know how they do it i really
don't send money in the right places
whatever but
i ended up on house arrest
um
had the ankle monitor on and uh
i was looking at like six years if i
violated
so
me and my infinite wisdom i cut it off
and i ran down to south florida
you know that old saying wherever you go
you take you with you
you know well i took me with me
uh i was stealing cars down there i was
[ __ ] i was doing all kind of horrible
things once you cut your ankle monitor
off you're on the run yeah yeah yeah i
ran for
it was about eight years are they
actively looking for you oh yeah they
were actually
chasing me out the back door tattoo
shops you know in florida like
they were diligently searching um
but uh
yeah i uh one of those stalling cars i
hit a telephone pole with
in delray
um
the transformer exploded above my head
and caught the neighborhood on fire it
was seven city blocks went black
um
yeah it was thirteen thousand dollars
damage to the city of delray
they found me like four blocks away i
had run up from the scene you know
i woke up in a jail cell the next
morning with a warrant for cutting the
ankle monitor off and somehow or another
they released me
so how i tiptoed out of the jail i knew
they [ __ ] up
but
you know
sticking with tradition i ran again uh
this time i ran down to key west
and um
that's again a whole nother world down
there you know duval street is is like a
little mini mardi gras every night
you know like you can literally
panhandle 100 bucks in 10 minutes it's
all tourists and
um but it's extremely expensive to live
down there you know but
you can
do what i did and it's live on a
sailboat
and the mooring field um
yeah it was
it's definitely a dark time you know i
went from this award-winning tattoo
artist that uh
you know
was really making a name for himself i
was getting invites you know
internationally
to
the guy with 27 cents in his pocket they
want to sell the gulf of mexico you know
just [ __ ]
trying to get by catching strawberry
grouper for breakfast
but um
ultimately everything ended up catching
up to me and um
believe it or not even though i was
looking at six years before i cut the
ankle monitor off i ended up doing a
measly six months
for all that [ __ ] yeah that's the lawyer
he's a he's an amazing person
um
you
know it's
i got to the point where
the whole trap house thing was
it was easy to do i had the last house i
was at i had uh
it was paid for
i only had property taxes gas and
electric
and i got a disability check
for uh schizoaffective disorder they
actually offered i didn't even
look into applying for the [ __ ]
that's how out of my [ __ ] mind i was
um
the point is the chat covered
all those expenses the house itself
and um
we were tattooing out of it the same old
[ __ ] the drugs prostitutes
you know
guns whatever made money i don't know
i reached a point where i had no fight
left in me
you know
um i was always a
pretty much of a fighter
a good bit of violence in my past and um
i lost every fight i got in
towards the end there i i got a phone
call from
michael lynch
michael lynch was the
uh
original guy behind felony fights and
cage versus khan
instead of advocating violence these
days he actually helps knuckleheads like
me get their [ __ ] together
and uh that phone call was hey if you
want to come out to la
possibly uh
get a tattoo shop off the ground you
know get your [ __ ] together we'd love to
have you
and that was all i needed to hear
i was done i was i couldn't [ __ ] take
it anymore um
i heard somebody say one time that
desperation is a gift
i was definitely given that gift because
with no hesitation i was on a plane in
three days i gave away the house and
everything in it
i came out to la with nothing didn't
even bring my tattoo equipment because i
didn't want the energy it held i wanted
to start over completely and i did
uh
i was i was actually michael owned uh a
vape shop because vaping was really
popular back then
this is four years ago four years ago
sunday actually sunday the 30th of four
years clean
um
i was tattooing out of the vape shop you
know
they had any meetings out back
um
about
three months in
i i met my my now wife
um
she came in we did a little friday the
13th special thing you know 13 bucks for
tattoo on friday the 13th
you know it's just a little gimmick that
is going on in the industry for quite
some time i've never even done it before
i didn't want to
but i did it anyway and i'm glad i did
because
on friday the 13th april of 18
this girl comes into the shop
get a tattoo and uh
we're the same height same eye color
same hair color we are both named chris
and we were both originally from
maryland
i stole a consent form to get her phone
number
we're now married um
i i it's amazing you know
because along the whole the lines of the
whole recovery network and community and
all aside from those similarities her
and i are completely different people
you know like
she's also from maryland but she grew up
about 45 minutes away from baltimore
you know
cows and corn fields and you know
she was actually homecoming queen where
i was like the the dropout degenerate
um
but we had
one main thing in common that was really
important and that was that desire to
just
build a new life a new healthy life you
know
um
and i i
we stayed involved
with the community
and
the
tattooing grew to the point where i'm at
with it now you know it might i kind of
wanted to get my career back on track
and
rebuild and uh
get to the point now where instead of
the vape shop
we have another location it's um
it's strictly tattooing it's a
interstate inc
um instead of interstate vape it's the
name of the old place
um
because
my business partner is michael lynch who
owns all the treatment centers and all
that good stuff
uh
we have a program in place now where we
can help other artists like myself with
addiction issues get their lives and
careers back on track
you know i guess you know i said before
i burnt it to the ground and i realized
because tattooing is such an anything
goes industry you know
like tattooing will magnify whatever
kind of person you are it's bizarre
you know um
when i was using
tattooing was
that was my in on everything you know uh
where
in the past when i i wanted to [ __ ]
get high i had to scrounge 20 bucks
people would come over and just throw
[ __ ] at me because it's the tattoo guy
you know
like it was uh
one incident where the guy actually came
over with [ __ ] kilos like these are
people who wouldn't give me the time of
day before but because of tattooing
they're all about i don't know what it
is but uh
it just it's always had that stigma
this time around
we did the complete opposite i have
pushed recovery through tattooing
to the point where
i have two artists working for me that
are both clean
um one of them i pulled from baltimore
where i was from so he could get his
[ __ ] together um
it's it's it's been a long it's been a
wild ride you know it really has and
here i am
able to give back
uh
which was
something i never thought i'd even be
interested in doing you know i was
extremely selfish self-centered but now
not these days uh
you know i sponsor guys in the 12-step
program
after going through the steps with a
sponsor myself
you know like i said our shop
it we don't even have
uh many clientele that aren't in the
program you know because southern
california a lot of people don't even
realize it but it's like the hub for
treatment centers it's huge
and uh
you know actually
with the shop
i'm able to
like i said do the complete opposite of
what i did before
and it's pretty [ __ ] amazing um
it's been a true blessing
um where were your drugs
what were my drugs
jesus
uh
i've done drugs most people never even
heard of man
literally [ __ ] hey you had so on a
daily basis my uh i would do heroin
cocaine
uh
usually around a
half a gallon of vodka
i have paul benzos occasionally meth on
top of that but since i was tattooing
i
had all walks of life coming through
the ravers would come over and they
would bring a bunch of psychedelics and
[ __ ] like that and
uh yeah bikers come through they bring
pcp
you know
i guess my point is like
just massive amounts of anything
or
every day you know that was my routine
for about 10 years
but uh what's what's the secret to
getting clean because you're clean now
oh yeah
okay how long have you been clean uh
like i said it's uh
january 30th just this past sunday it
was four years
um what helped you do it
what helped me
what what advice can you get
you gotta want it
plain and simple like i said early on
uh desperation was a gift
and
i was desperate i wanted nothing more
than to change my life i wanted to get
back on track
between that
desire first and foremost and
staying involved
with
you know i've i realized at the ripe old
age of 40 the importance of community
it's a huge part of it it's just
staying involved with a network of
like-minded individuals who also want to
just stay together to stay clean and
keep their [ __ ] together
but uh
you know
i think
one of the things that
probably one of the most important
things is
i never thought i'd say this but the 12
steps
it really helped you take a look at
yourself your behaviors
past and present and
break down exactly why
you're
running from whatever it is i'm running
from
to begin with does that make sense
um
yeah man it's uh
it definitely starts with that desire
you know and it has to be
it has to be a desire to stay clean it's
almost as strong as
the desire to get high
i say almost because
drugs have a craving involved
you know somebody like me
would hold on to a resentment
for a [ __ ] lifetime you know if i had
issues with somebody
10 years ago
20 years ago
i'm still holding on to that you know
what i mean i gotta come after you and
i i had to be taught to let go of that
stuff because it only [ __ ] you know
like the person i'm upset with or upset
about doesn't even know
that i'm holding onto this [ __ ] they
don't they're they've not they don't
give a [ __ ]
um
aside from that man like
[Music]
i uh
like i said i had had enough
that was the biggest thing you know
and as a result i'm able to help others
you know reach a point where i'm at
like um i started something similar to
this where i'm uh
i you know tattooing at the shop i keep
hearing these stories because while i'm
working i got i got other people who
we've got these crazy ass stories
they're clean now and
we start talking we start bullshitting
and um
i started filming their stories like
you're doing uh the broken crayons show
cause
even broken crayons still color you know
i thought it was a cool friend of mine
came up with the the title and i ran
with it um i
it it just it was a metaphor that worked
man you know because
people like myself and
so many others are straight up
broken
what do you think the the reason that
drug addiction is
such a common thing in our country
yes
oh wow
that's right it's almost a loaded
question you know with the
pharmaceutical companies and
a friend of the family like you know my
mother's friends and [ __ ] who were
they their kids were nothing like me
they grew up uh you know
valedictorian type is you know status
when you know perfect gpa all that good
stuff
and
as a result of like a sports
injury they're dead now because they got
hooked on oxycontin or
you know it's just it's it's absolutely
insane man there's so many [ __ ]
contributing factors you know
um
i don't care which side of the the game
you're on it's big money
you know i've always said no matter what
the issue is with
society government whatever follow the
money
you know
and it's uh
you know people at the top of those
situations they don't give a [ __ ]
who gets hurt who dies you know
like this fentanyl [ __ ] what's going on
now
you know before i came out here
that the eight months prior to coming to
l.a like i said the whole trap house
situation
i saw more overdoses in that eight
months when when fentanyl was starting
to take hold then i saw the entire 25
years total combined like combined
prior
that's [ __ ] disturbing
to me it would be bad for business you
know what it means like
you're losing all your kill your [ __ ]
clientele but
i don't know
something about it
but yeah
there's there's so many reasons you know
for somebody like me i started using
when i was so young that um
you know i was still that scared little
boy whose father left
all the way up to the age of 40.
if that makes sense you know because
whatever i was running from originally
was
compounded by
the next
[ __ ] that i brought on myself
year after year to year creating more
problems on top of the problems i was
running from
you know and it's it's crazy because
once i finally got clean and i came to
that realization
i thought wow what a [ __ ]
you know what i mean like
i'm running from something you know at
the age of 40 it took place when i was
five
it sounds pathetic to me now that i'm on
the other side of it
and uh
i don't know it's a hard realization for
people to come to it really is i know
because i i talk to some of these
younger cats man i'm like
you know this [ __ ] is gonna kill you
it's not a matter if but a matter of
when
you know if you do fentanyl you will die
it's you know it's not like [ __ ] was
back in the day you know when somebody
got high and fell on the floor back in
the day we would laugh because we need
to get back up it seldomly
didn't rise to the feet but now
it's all she wrote
you know
um
it's
the thing is i could i could tell these
kids that are blowing blue in the face
this shit's gonna kill you
they'll give them [ __ ] they don't even
seem to it doesn't phase them it's
bizarre
but i've been there so i understand it
i don't know it's confusing situation
man it really is but um i know if
nine people that was close to the that
have
passed away in like the past three four
weeks
nine and you know that's
you know i had uh
my shop i kind of teamed up with another
addict was um
making watches
i had him do some custom launches for me
with my logo on the face
found out you know by opening facebook
that he was gone
um just so many people you end up
getting close to and
like that they're gone
um
gotta cut my hair gone
yeah the list just it goes on and on
all right it's really just it's got its
[ __ ] claws and everybody you know and
they're putting it in everything which
doesn't make any sense to me you know
fentanyl is a downer why would you put
it in cocaine
you know who am i
obviously
not that kind of business man because i
don't get it
tell me about tattooing
why is tattooing so popular
well
when i got into it um
it wasn't as
mainstream as it is today
got into it about 19 years ago
but then uh
the tv shows
there's there's definitely different
ways to look at that you know for for
guys like us
you know at first we were like this is
[ __ ] you know what i mean like don't
drag this many people into this you know
it's almost like an elite few that were
capable and
um
that was so popular well that was the
other thing that was the other side of
it like we we noticed that
people who would never get tattooed
before were watching shows like miami
inc back then and they were coming in
and getting heavily tattooed so
you know it had its pros and cons but
um
all right i tattooed a a greek orthodox
priest like this [ __ ] is for everybody
now
um
i think
you know
self-expression
you know a lot of
memorial type
tattoos there's so many different
situations where people get tattooed um
i'm not really sure why but i'm glad it
is because it pays my bills
what's the craziest tattoo you've done
yeah i get that question a lot and uh
well i i had i got a fun one for you uh
my wife uh i said earlier my nickname is
church my wife has church parking only
right here
um
i had one this one dude years ago i did
a
[ __ ] on his ribs so the armpit hair is
pubes
just you know what i mean like just off
the wall [ __ ] you know
some of this stuff people ask for is
just
downward crazy some of the names they
just want to get like their kids name
uh the one the one ladies she wrote it
down nozmo king was the name
then if you write it down and read it it
says no smoking i'm like what the hell
is this i saw it on the way into the
delivery room
all right
i interviewed a guy a couple years ago
mexican guy who's probably in prison
probably a prison tattoo
[ __ ] eater across his upper lip there
you go
then you know
i'm not sure what that's going to lead
to run it you know any one guy who
so distraught man like
because his nephew died and wanted to
get something for his nephew but he
wanted his nephew's name across his
forehead i was like dude i gotta
understand you're grieving i get that
you're hurting but
really like you put on your arm or
something man
i don't know
it's it's crazy i i can't think of more
off the top of my head but i noticed
some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] i did a shocker
recently
you know ah these two fingers are
covered and come this was covered in
[ __ ] like
you know uh
[ __ ]
yeah
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your in your
crazy life
that's simple man
ride the wave
stop getting in my own [ __ ] way and
just watch it unfold you know
to the point where i'm
literally able to take a step back and
just
process things and let things happen
if that makes sense you know um
we're always so eager to do and say and
and [ __ ] get in
our own way and for me especially very
impulsive you know
just being
patient and and like i said ride the
wave
watch it unfold
beautiful
all right chris thank you so much for
sharing your story
hi linda you did great
you